[Music]
after nearly two years of tight
restrictions the u.s borders are now
open to vaccinated coveted negative
travelers and that means international
flights are flying again at mccarran a
virgin atlantic flight was the first to
touch down earlier today 8 news now
reporter sally jaramillo is live at the
airport with more on the big day sally
it needs lots of good energy and big
smiles as many vaccinated tourists
finally arrive to las vegas many saying
they are ready to gamble others happy to
see their families after such a long
time
the skies are finally back open for
international travelers we have waited
20 months for this day 20 months ago was
our last flight virgin happened to be
our last flight out of this airport
back in march of 2020
and travelers treated to a fabulous las
vegas welcome it is wonderful for las
vegas you know it is the essence of our
economy and and mccarran the airport is
the gateway to that economy director of
aviation for mccarran says the demand to
fly is high the number of seats that
they're selling is you know
way over average we've been here for
nearly two years so it's very
different exciting forgetting all the
worry about getting here
getting vaccines and getting farms and
getting to the airport both rosemary and
andrew allison are from scotland and
excited they get to see their sons after
such a long time apart they say a bit of
a hassle of a process to getting the
right forms but relieved it all worked
out as for what's next we already have
heard from copa that will come from
latin america and klm that will come
from amsterdam so yet another gateway
from europe
will be coming in
shortly after the new year
proving everyone needs a piece of las
vegas
now out here live there were a total of
240 passengers on the flight and no
issues reported sally haramiyo live
local now